Ross Tucker sent out a tweet this
morning Ross of course sometimes fills
in on this show former NFL lineman
Sirius XM NBC Sports Network analyst and
Ross all let you I'll let you read your
own tweet and then we'll discuss well
yeah I mean obviously the big topic Dan
this morning has been Thursday Night
Football and what Doug Baldwin said and
a lot of people are complaining about it
but you know the two points I made this
morning is that number one you know the
players get fifty five percent of the
television package and so Thursday Night
Football for just this year is over five
hundred million dollars that means the
players are getting over 275 million
bucks which is over 150 grand per player
to play one Thursday game and then the
other point I mentioned is that I only
did it once and I played from oh one oh
wait and I remember I don't think they
had Thursday night now but when I was
playing in Dallas no - we played
Jacksonville on a Sunday was a physical
game IRA after the game had to go back
to the trainer to the Cowboys facility
because it was Thanksgiving week and
that was kind of the routine in Dallas
you knew that evidently that was my
first year there so it was a rough week
but here's the thing when you plan on
Thursday you don't do anything it's like
the easiest week for a player ever all
you do is like rehab and try to heal and
have a couple walk through then we
played on Thanksgiving we won I got the
whole weekend off which was awesome I
went home had my fifth year I school
reunion I mean there's to me there's two
things here if you asked every player
forget the monetary part of it if you
asked every player I think it'd be about
50/50 because I saw some current guys
like Tyler use cheque and other guys
liked my tweet about liking Thursday
night because of the easy workweek and
then getting the entire weekend off but
more importantly than that then all the
people that complain about it if you
went to every player would be 90 percent
of the guys would say okay for one
Thursday night game I'll get an extra
150 grand yeah you know play I'll play
one Thursday night a year for under 50
grand so why are the Seahawks upset is
it just because Richard Sherman is out
for the season
well I mean last week Richie incognito
yes
planing about it for Buffalo after they
lost I think number one people are
always going to be averse to change or
getting out of their routine mean nobody
nobody in life likes getting out of the
agenda a lot of guys that didn't like
playing Monday night games or Sunday
night games because you had no hotel
room all day if you ask a lot of guys
they would want every game to be Sunday
at once I think part of it is just
change but I also think a lot of the
economic issues dan I don't think
players will you look at it that way I
think they look at it like I got a four
year deal for 20 million with eight
guaranteed and that's what I'm getting I
don't need a realized wait a minute the
money has to come from somewhere it has
to come from NBC and CBS and Amazon
Prime to make that salary cap go up and
that we're all benefiting greatly and
that doesn't even count being the only
game on the exposure I mean Amazon put
30 million dollars in the promotion of
their I mean there's a lot of benefits
that players get from playing that one
Thursday night game I don't think when
you're a current player you really think
about the big picture financial aspect
of it
we saw moment last night with Russell
Wilson where the officials sent him off
to the sidelines and I'm assuming when
you're sent off you have to go through
concussion protocol it didn't look like
he went through concussion protocol I
understand how you don't want to go
through concussion protocol but what
what is the league supposed to do in a
situation like this I didn't have to
find the Seahawks he walked off sat down
he missed the play wasn't happy about it
was was wasn't happy that was taking too
long to come and check him and he goes
back in and then after they punt the
ball then he comes over and does more of
the concussion protocol I don't think
that's how it's supposed to be there I
don't think the concussion protocol is
say how to play and then come back in
and then after you got to the series
over then we'll check you I mean if all
Anderson or won't Coleman or whoever if
they think there's an issue then you
need to be out until they check you and
I don't know that'll be fine I mean the
Seahawks will be fine because that's not
the protocol and that's a real bad look
on national TV Thank You Ross we
appreciate it have a good weekend
thank you absolutely man looking for
them I'm at Fenway Park tonight Dan for
brown and Dartmouth's I'm McLaughlin
we'll be watching
oh nice I'll watch that
yeah you know Friday night Ivy League
football and right there with you man
I'll be watching Thank You Ross thanks
man that's why Ross Tucker for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]